สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
เตรียมวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 24 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคม
ไม่เห็นคมนะคะเห็นแค่สีน้ำ
ขยับลงมาข้างล่าง
ได้ค่ะ
เดือนสิงหาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 8 นะคะปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้ 9 โมง 6 นาทีค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงยังรู้สึกแบบเป็นยังไงบ้าง
ง่วงนอนหรอ
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะวันนี้ครูเรียมจะไม่ง่วงนอน
แน่นอนเพราะว่าครูหญิงจะมีเกมมาเล่นกับ
ครูเรียมครูเรียมเนี่ยต้องคิด
ต้องคิดแต่ว่าก่อนที่จะเล่นเกมเนี่ยขอถาม
คำถามก่อนคือเกมก็เป็นคำถามแหละแต่ว่าขอ
ถามคำถามก่อนถามอะไรคะครูหญิงถามว่าครู
เรียมเนี่ยเป็นคนที่ชอบสัตว์ไหมคะแบบหมา
แมวนก
จระเข้
เป็นคนชอบไหมอาจจะชอบดูรายการเกี่ยวกับ
สัตว์
เลี้ยงชอบค่ะชอบสัตว์ชอบเล่นชอบเล่นแล้ว
ก็ชอบดู
ถ้าเกิดเป็นหมาเป็นแมวเนี่ยก็จะชอบเล่น
ด้วยด้วยแต่ว่าเป็นงูเนี่ยชอบดูเฉยๆไม่
เล่นนะไม่เล่นเหมือนกัน
ค่ะเพราะว่าเกมที่จะมาเล่นวันนี้เนี่ยก็
จะเป็นเกมเกี่ยวกับสัตว์นี่แหละแต่ว่าครู
เรียมถ้าครูเรียมชอบสัตว์ครูเรียมก็จะรู้
จักสัตว์หลายๆชนิด
โดยที่วิธีการเล่นนะคะก็คือครูหญิงเนี่ย
จะมีคำถามอยู่ทั้งหมด 16 ข้อนะ 16 ข้อผู้
หญิงจะไม่ถามครูเรียงแบบข้อ 1 ข้อ 2 ข้อ 3
นะคะมี 16 ข้อเนี่ยให้ครูเรียนเลือกมาเลย
ว่า
อยากได้คำถามข้อที่เท่าไหร่
เราก็ควรเรียนก็เลือกคำถามแล้วผู้หญิงก็
จะบอกแล้วก็ครูเรียนก็ตอบคำถามนั้น
ได้ค่ะหวังว่าจะไม่ยาก
ไม่ยากไม่ยากถ้าครูเรียมชอบสัตว์ไม่ยาก
[เพลง]
แบบสดไม่ได้แล้วค่ะไม่ได้เดี๋ยวเจอคำถาม
เดี๋ยวเล่นเกมเดี๋ยวก็แบบสดชื่นแล้วก็
ตื่นเองค่ะ
มาค่ะพร้อมค่ะ
มีคำถามทั้งหมด
ครูเรียมอยากจะเล่นข้อไหนเป็นข้อแรกให้
ครูเรียมเลือกเลยค่ะคำถามข้อที่ 1
เอาข้อที่ 1 เลยหรอคะข้อที่ 1 นะคะให้ครู
เรียมเนี่ยบอกสัตว์ 3 ชนิดที่มันกระโดด
ได้เพราะว่าสัตว์เนี่ยบางครั้งมันก็เดิน
บินว่ายน้ำแล้วกระโดด
ให้บอกชื่อสัตว์ชื่อสัตว์ 3 ชนิดที่
กระโดดได้ออกกำลังจะบอกเลย
จิงโจ้
ออสเตรเลียมีจิงโจ้เยอะๆจิงโจ้
อะไรอีกนักเรียนอาจจะคิดได้แล้วนะแบบดู
เรียบอยู่ตอนนี้
อะไรที่กระโดดได้หรอ
ความจริงได้หลายอย่างมากเลยนะใช่
นี่คือ
จิงโจ้เนอะตั๊กแตน
กระโดดได้เลยหรอแต่กระโดดได้
ตั๊กแตนบินได้แล้วก็กระโดดได้
ตั๊กแตนเนี่ยนะคะใช่
โอเคตั๊กแตนใช่ๆว่าผู้หญิงก็คิดถึงไอ้พวก
นี้แหละกระโดดได้เก่งมากค่ะครูเรียม
ข้อต่อไปครูเรียมอยากได้คำถามข้อที่เท่า
ไหร่คะ
ข้อที่ 16
ข้อสุดท้ายใช่ไหม
5 ชนิดที่อยู่ที่แอนตาร์กติกา
ผู้หญิงเปลี่ยนได้ไหมเปลี่ยนเป็นข้ออื่น
ไม่ได้แล้วสัตว์ 5 ชื่อสัตว์ 5 ชนิดนะคะ
ที่มันอาศัยอยู่ที่แอนตาร์กติกา
แอนตาร์กติกามีสัตว์อะไรบ้าง
มันมีบ้านมันอยู่ที่แอนตาร์ค่ะประเทศไทย
ไม่มีที่แบบแล้วหนาว
มีน้ำแข็งมีหิมะไม่ยากนะอย่างน้อยกูเรียก
ก็น่าจะได้ 1 อย่างละหมีมีขาว
หมีขาว
ได้ค่ะ
แพนกวิน
ขาว
เพนกวิน
ถูกไหม
เด็กผู้หญิงดูก่อนนะว่า
หมีขาว
อยู่แอนตาร์กติกาไหม
ไม่มีนะ
หรอคือหญิงรู้ไหมว่าเรียนต่อจากอะไรลืม
ตอบจ้า
อยู่ที่ไหน
อยู่ข้างล่างใช่ไหม
คือโลกของเรามันจะมีขั้วโลกเหนือแล้วก็
ขั้วโลกใต้ใช่ไหม
มีข่าวไม่ใช่นะมีขาวอยู่ที่นี่
แคนาดารัสเซียหมีขาวมากๆแต่แอนตาร์กติกา
มันจะอยู่ขั้วโลกใต้แต่เพนกวินเพนกวินใช่
ค่ะเพนกวิน
แมวน้ำ
แมวน้ำใช่
สงสารตัวเองมากเลยตอนนี้
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
เปิด
แมวน้ำให้นักเรียนดูก่อนนะคะแต่นักเรียน
บอกว่าอะไรคือแมวน้ำ
จริงๆอ่ะถ้ามันเป็นเพนกวินน่ะผู้หญิงก็
สามารถให้ผู้เรียนได้หลายอย่างนะเพราะว่า
เพนกวินเนี่ยมันก็มีหลายชนิดอันนี้คือแมว
น้ำนะคะ
แมวน้ำ
[เพลง]
เพนกวินสิงโตทะเล
ใช่แมวน้ำไหมคล้ายๆกันใช่ไหมสิงโตทะเล
สิงโตทะเล
จะตอบว่าปลาได้ไหม
มันมีปลาที่อยู่นะ
เขามีปลาอะไรกัน
ปลาโลมา
ใช่ค่ะ
เราก็
แมวน้ำ
[เพลง]
สิงโตทะเล
อื้ม
[เพลง]
สิงโตทะเลเพนกวิน
โอเคพอแล้วพวกมันยากเนาะเราไม่ค่อยรู้จัก
นะคะ
เรียมไม่ได้มีบ้านอยู่ที่
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เพนกวินอย่างเดียว
โอเคข้อต่อไปครูเรียนจะเลือกข้ออะไร
ข้อ
ข้อ 2
ชื่อสัตว์ 5 ชนิดที่อยู่ที่แอฟริกา
ไม่ใช่แอนตาร์แล้วนะแอฟริกา
มียีราฟ
นักเรียนรู้จักน้องคงไม่ต้องให้ดูรูปนะคะ
[เพลง]
สิงโต
ใช่ค่ะสิงโตผู้เรียนเคยดู
ไลอ้อนคิงไหมจำได้ไหมว่ามีอะไรบ้างใช่ๆ
นี่แหละกำลังคิดอยู่
มีอะไรบ้าง
มีเสือ
เสือสามน้องเสือ
4 งู
ดูว่าครูเรียนจะตอบว่า
ม้าลาย
นะคะแต่ว่าได้เนาะ
ยีราฟสิงโตเสืองูแล้วก็ช้าง
จะเลือกคำถามข้ออะไรข้อ 1 ข้อ 2 ข้อ 16
เนี่ยไปแล้วเนาะถ้าเหลือ 3  4  5  6  7  8
9  10  11  12  13  14  15
เหลือข้อ 15
ข้อ 15
ให้ครูเรียมบอกชื่อสัตว์ 5 ชนิดที่มีขน
สัตว์ที่มีผล
ง่ายมากแต่คิดก่อนมีอะไรบ้าง
น้องหมามีขนนะคะแบบบางชนิดก็ขนยาวมากๆใช่
ไหมขนยาวมากๆใช่ 2 ค่ะอะไรอีกคะมีขนแมว
แมวมีขน 3 ลิง
ลิงมีขน 4
นมก็มีขนนะนกก็มีขนใช่ค่ะนกเราก็เรียกว่า
ขนนกใช่ขนาดนี้ก็
เข้าแล้วแหละไก่
ก็มีขน
เราเก็บไว้ใช้อย่างอื่น
โอเคได้ๆ
ข้อต่อไปค่ะครูเรียงจะเลือกข้ออะไร
เลือกข้อ 10
ข้อ 10  1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10
[เพลง]
บอกชื่อสัตว์ 3 ชนิดที่เวลาที่มันท้อง
แล้วมันต้องวางไข่
ออกลูกเป็นไข่เออให้บอกชื่อสัตว์ที่มัน
ออกลูกเป็นไข่ไม่ได้เป็นตัว
เต่า
เต่าออกลูกเป็นไข่ใช่ไหมเป็นไข่แล้วก็
เปลี่ยนเป็นเต่า
[เพลง]
มีอะไรคะตอบซ้ำไม่ได้หรอผู้หญิงไง
มีเต่ามีเป็ดอีก 1 ชนิดค่ะ
เต่าเป็ดเราก็แล้วก็อะไรดีคะนักเรียน
ออกลูกเป็นไข่หรอ
[เพลง]
วางไข่วางไข่
ใช่ปลา
อ๋อเหมือนเหมือนไข่ปลาคาเวียร์อะไรอย่าง
นี้หรอ
เออใช่
ปลาก็ออกลูกเป็นไข่นะคะ
[เพลง]
ข้อต่อไปครบแล้วค่ะ 3 ชนิดใช่ไหมคะ 3
ชนิด
[เพลง]
รู้จักสัตว์เยอะมากๆอ่ะก็ต่อไปค่ะ
ให้ครูเรียนบอกชื่อสัตว์ 3 ชนิดที่มีเขา
มีเขา
อะไรที่เขา
กวาง
กวางเรนเดียร์
ใช่กวางมีเขาอะไรคะ 2
มีเขา
วัวก็มีเขานะ
อีกหนึ่งชนิด
ควายก็มีเขา
เก่งมาก
[เพลง]
หกเจ็ดแปด
ๆๆ
ชื่อสัตว์
3 ชนิดพอ
ที่เราเนี่ยดื่มนมของมันได้
อันนี้ซ้ำได้ไม่เป็นไร
[เพลง]
เราดื่มนมแพะ
แพ้เราดื่มนมแพะ
เราดื่มนมนมวัว
กับนมวัวหม้อ
ดื่มนมอะไรนี่
นมควายก็ดื่มได้นะยืมได้ค่ะนมควายเขาก็
เอาไปทำเป็นชีสด้วยนะ
ทำมาจากนมควายใส่ค่ะ
เก่งมาก
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ให้ครูเรียนบอกชื่อสัตว์ที่เขาว่ามันเป็น
นักล่าสัตว์ที่มันเป็นนักล่าก็คือมันจะ
ออกหาอาหารน่ะ
ก็คือสิงโตเพราะว่าผู้เรียนตอบสิงโตไป
แล้วใช่ไหมสิงโตเนี่ยมันเป็นสัตว์ที่เป็น
นักล่านะคะมันจะเดินไปแล้วมันก็เห็นกวาง
เรนเดียร์ใช่ไหมเห็นกวางแล้วมันก็จะแล้ว
มันก็จะเอามากินนะแล้วมันจะวิ่งตามแบบ
เนี้ยวิ่งล่าเนาะเราเรียกว่าเป็นนักล่า
ให้ผู้เรียนบอกชื่อสัตว์ 3 ชนิดที่เป็น
นักล่ามีแบบ
ไฮยีน่า
ให้ดีนะนี่
ในเอ่อ
[เพลง]
มี
อะไรนะ
เสือก็ใช่เสือก็เป็นสัตว์นักล่า
เสือก็เป็นสัตว์นักล่าวิ่งเหมือนกัน
เราก็
มีอะไรอ่ะหมาป่าหมาป่ากับไฮยีน่าเหมือน
กันไหมไม่เหมือนค่ะ
หมาป่าก็เป็นนักล่านะใช่ไหมใช่นะคะ
แต่เขาจะล่าล่าสัตว์แบบเป็นฝูงอ่ะเขาเขา
จะมีเป็นฝูงก็คือมีหมาป่าหมาป่าหมาป่า
หลายๆตัวอยู่ด้วยกัน
อันนี้คือไฮยีน่า
นะคะก็เก่งมากนะคะเย้นักเรียนก็จะรู้ว่า
จริงๆครูเรียมก็รู้จักสัตว์หลายชนิดนะ
เก่งมาก
เหมือนกันถ้าไม่เปิด Google นะคะ
ใช่ไม่ได้เปิด Google ผู้หญิงต้องมอบ
ไฮยีน่าให้เรียมเป็นรางวัล
ได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงจะส่งรูปที่ครูหญิง
ให้นักเรียนดูเนี่ยให้ผู้เรียนเป็นรางวัล
นะคะ
[เพลง]
โอเคค่ะก็วันนี้มาเล่นเกมสนุกๆเนาะเกี่ยว
กับสัตว์นะคะเดี๋ยวเราค่อยมาเจอกันใหม่ใน
วีดีโอหน้า
เดี๋ยวเจอกันค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะ